in approximately 10:17 a.m. a student
reported that a male student was
reported to have a brought a handgun to
the school and was currently in
possession of this handgun the school's
resource officer immediately responded
to the classroom the suspect would not
remove his hands from his pocket and
continued ignore officers commands the
suspect removed the handgun from his
waistband
and pointed it at the officers an
officer was forced to discharge his
firearm striking the suspect officers
immediately provided life-saving medical
attention the remaining students were
evacuated from the classroom in the
school was put on lockdown a firearm was
recovered the suspect is a 17 year old
male he was transported to the hospital
and is in stable condition
I know that this was a terrifying day
for many students and parents I guess
what is important is the partnership
between the school and the city for
having a school resource officer as well
as all the work that is done by the
police department the fire department
and the school district and making sure
that students know what to do and the
teachers know what to do work today
you